osez être belle voilà le message à
retenir de l'atelier conseil en image
organisé au centre social de magny les
hameaux dans une ambiance de salon de
thé 14 femmes sont venues papauté look
maquillage et coiffure avec une
spécialiste si on grossit ou si on ainsi
ou après une maladie bon bref on a
vraiment du mal à s'habiller parce que
ce corps ils changent et on adapte
jamais les vêtements donc on va prendre
à décomplexer et surtout à rééquilibrer
avec le vêtement se corse pour
dissimuler des hanches généreuses éviter
le gilet long 10 femmes et préférer une
veste courte qui donne du volume en haut
du corps un des précieux conseils
partager sans tabou donc bien d'écouter
mon expliqué sur sur les bijoux comme on
porte les bijoux quel type des bijoux
peuvent aller l'école aussi je me rends
compte que mon col aujourd'hui ça
peut-être pas le cas l'idéal qui me met
pas forcément en valeur donc ça pète ça
permet aussi de se rendre compte que
parfois c'est des choses qui sont bien
pour 1 % nous qui parfois des choses qui
sont moins bien celle qui assume et le
plus leur corps repartent confortés dans
leur idée de la féminité
l'élégance avant le corps c'est à dire
qu'on soit ronde demain ce grand ou
petit
ce qui est important c'est de se sentir
bien et de prendre soin de soi pour
prendre soin d'elle cette manie coise a
pris une semaine de congés afin de
participer à toutes les activités
proposées par sa ville dans le cadre de
l'évènement femmes du monde qui se
clôturera le 8 mars lors de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes